oh it's about to get real magical
[Music]
i'm sarah oh my god and i'm curly
we're fascinated by religion today we're
going to learn about wicca and
participate in a wicked ritual that'll
hopefully give us more success in our
careers
[Music]
today yes we're gonna start our journey
into the realm of witches you know i'm
so excited for this
i got extra crystal they put little
feather in and there's like yes i don't
know anything i know about like
pointy hats cauldrons i don't think any
of that's real it could very well be
released
i treat it as like a connection to the
earth we're homies like i look at these
trees and i'm like i got you when you
got me and i know it
before the ritual we wanted to get some
background information on wicca so we
traveled to the green man in north
hollywood to talk to an expert
[Music]
well this magical place is the green
man's store it's
in north hollywood california you are on
your spiritual path
you're sort of witchy curious
1950s okay gerald gardner in england
had his wiccan tradition so wicca 50s
and 60s it started to come into the
united states
paganism has it's become an umbrella
term
and wicca has also become an umbrella
term and the past
few decades you have the dynamics you
have earth-based spirituality you have
the reclaiming tradition
well some water really feels good for
dancing i can just feel like my throat
itchy so do you hear if i keep drinking
water well we're doing this okay
here's some other basic wicca info
hashtag wikfo jk that's stupid i'm sorry
wiccans believe in the existence of
magic and that by practicing magic
through rights spells and potions they
can affect
change many wiccans live by an ethical
code called the we can read
that states and it harm none do what ye
will
many are pan or polytheistic and
recognize the goddess and god
among many other deities wiccans with
shared beliefs form covens with whom
they practice
beliefs practices and structure can vary
drastically across kevin's
[Music]
so every crystal has a different quality
or
essence you can charge these with you
like a kind of a neutral you can charge
these up with your intention on the full
moon how do you
charge them first again i know zero
first you clean first you need to clean
it so you can put it in a bowl of salt
water under the full moon
you can um clean it by air with incense
or sage
and you charge it up using your magic
and your personal juice
your juice you juice i got a lot of
personal drinks you do
so pendulums are part of divination
so you have to sort of tune in get quiet
and you're basically telling the
pendulum
what is a yes and a no this is a yes and
then the pendulum
and this is a no so then when you're
going to the health food store and you
have to decide what kind of vitamin c
you want to get and which one is better
for you you can get your pendulum
yeah every candle has a different color
and you've got two tone candles what are
these cats down here
two-toned ones well this is what you are
you know absorbing or you're releasing
and then this is what you're bringing in
there's also some my
i like a camera there's some phallic
candles as well i didn't see those at
first
what would you use a penis candle for
we're just going to ask yeah what do you
think we would use a penis
well i don't know because i could be
like i would love to kill his boner
think about the driving primal force of
masculinity
that is represented in that phallic
symbol wizards aren't a thing
right that's not real and what are
wizards what do wizards come into it
how does this work do you eat it do you
burn it do you smoke it
uh you can burn it root stem leaf branch
berry
can i rub this on me sure
like the prospective frost there's
nothing left dragon's blood is
very powerful to heal cuts what about my
hangnails
uh yeah probably that's a common problem
it seems like a lot of work and i watch
too much television
to have time to do this that's what i
feel like too i got the crystal and then
i also got
an incense burner i got incense
i got coal and then i got herbs to burn
i'm excited tomorrow to like actually
see what happens because we're going to
be doing
yes all right so i'm going to put my
cross away
i'll find my giant jesus tattoo on my
back
perfect today we are participating
in a wiccan ceremony ritual
that is hopefully going to lead to some
career success
i'm just hoping that i have a little bit
more money in my wallet by the end of
the day
you expect that quicker turnaround yeah
i believe in miracles i want to be like
a savant at
you know being a witch i'm nervous that
i'm gonna get the church giggles while
i'm there
well hopefully we don't that doesn't
happen today to prevent making complete
fools of ourselves during the ritual we
enlisted a little help
i'm yvonne conway williams i have
actually been practicing witchcraft
since 1982.
i'm an ordained elder high priestess
in my coven it sounds very badass
the witchcraft was something that i
wanted to do to kind of take control of
my life
what are some of the like most common
misconceptions
let's see the biggest one i think is
that we worship the devil there are
witches
who do but in wicca the christian devil
isn't even recognized as an existing
entity per se
now we're gonna get ready for this
service we're gonna get ready it's okay
all right it's gonna be amazing is there
anything that
we should know always go clockwise the
energy that we're good at yeah
are we now after the ceremony close to
being witches
you've now had experience but uh a lot
of traditions it'll be like a year and a
day studying
oh i'm gonna get to work
what i'll have you guys do is as you
come in i will anoint you
with some oil on your forehead which
would be about where your third eye is
i think we'd start with a grounding to
make sure that you're all centered
before we start
shake off any tension or stress you may
be carrying let go of your worries
and visualize roots growing from the
base of your spine down your legs
out your feet down to the earth's
underground rivers with its visualized
tree branches let yourself be at one
with the earth
and the universe we'll do a cleansing of
the space
and creating sacred space earth and
water by casting thee no spell or
unknown hindrance be
except in true accord with me and as my
will so might it be
so motive what's called calling on the
quarters which would be the north south
east and west and bringing in those
particular energies to kind of help
hold down our circle so to speak
hail ye lords of the western quadrant i
do summon stir and call you up that you
may bear witness to this right
and lend your protection in the west and
then i'll do what's called casting the
circle and casting the circle is
creating a an energetic barrier we'll
raise a cone of power to kind of raise
more energy
feel the energy rising up through your
roots past the underground rivers rocks
and soil back
until it hovers at the bottom of your
feet feeling the energy moving around
passing around faster continuously as if
it was a blanket
disconnect it from your hands then we'll
call in the lord and the lady
great goddess mighty mother raise the
power of the sacred right
refresh us with your kiss and grant us
the pleasure
and peace of your company and then we'll
start on the work
today we're going to be working on
success any color piece of paper
bullet point words of something that you
want to
manifest in your career are we gonna
have to read this out loud no okay
you're going to first look at these oils
there's a variety for different purposes
and you're going to apply one to a
candle
this one oh beauty oh it smells
delicious
element of earth i ask you what was cool
is that you can participate
in a way that you don't normally get to
in in
in other religions yeah element of air i
ask for your aid
everything also like as it was happening
it made sense to me even though like
i had never experienced it before and
then we're gonna have cakes and ale
or actually uh mini cinnamon buns and
martinelli's
and then we will do everything in
reverse
it is ended blessed be
usually after a ritual we'll do a feast
and the whole
point behind the feast is to kind of
pull our energy back down
[Music]
i had a lot of fun doing it i was up in
the sun i was deep in the earth
i felt like i also was a little awkward
because at one point i walked the wrong
way
and i was like the other way and i had
to walk the other way
it's sort of like farting in yoga class
i don't part in yoga classes yeah
everybody
parks barter yoga farter
i really like the elements where you're
getting your power
like your source of energy from the
earth that part really spoke to me
because i think
nature is like the greatest source of
power
in you know the world people thinking
that there's something going on whether
it be like satanic or the evil it's
that's like a really common
misconception
uh and i think it's definitely just more
about your own
energy it felt great it actually felt
like just a nice positive
positive ceremony that we were just
sharing with friends and you get like a
fun snack at the end
now whenever sarah goes to yoga we all
know i don't go to yoga that much
because i was banned for farming